we are back with none other than vin
diesel give it up
now is a look at his new movie f9 so
what's dom up to you know in this fast
and furious installment what are you
doing
this one's fascinating because
what we one of the things that you want
to do when you're
um
involved in in creating a franchise like
this a mythology
is to try to defy expectations and what
we all
know about dom tereto is his loyalty to
family
at all cost what we discover in this one
and the reason why we discover it is
because he's a father now
and when you whenever you have
kids you reflect
on your own yeah you start going wait
what did that mean and what you know we
we look
at our parents in a different prison
once
we become parents and we need to do that
to better
be parents right what our goal in life
every parent in the world wakes up in
the morning thinking
how can i be a better parent it's common
it's all of us i hope that's true
[Laughter]
but i believe that to be do so in
looking in reflecting on that and
actually going
what's interesting about fast nine is
that we go back
to the first franchise to the first
film to that iconic moment where he's
talking about
why he's so scared of the car to paul
walker
and we actually uncover that scenario
and what that means and we find
a broken brotherhood yeah and that
broken brotherhood
is what comes to haunt dom in fastnine
oh wow well speaking of family um your
son's in it right
vincent yes my son isn't that's okay so
is it
terrifying because you're like i hope he
does well i want him to do well but at
the same time is he terrified because
you know you're he doesn't get terrified
too much oh he's falling his new kids
are
very very bold he's actually he just the
other day presented a new car
company to justin and i and assets both
to invest in it
so oh my gosh that kid yeah wow he um
so here's i didn't
invite him to play a role in this
the fast family is so
truly a family that i'm working
[Music]
with justin lynn the day he was born
so i say goodbye to justin lynn get on a
plane go to new york
and receive my son that's ten years ago
so when we're filming so he they
obviously
grown to be family themselves they know
each other yeah
and justin thought it would be a good
idea for him to play
younger dom but i didn't necessarily
think it would be a great idea because
it's a scene that i'm in did you see the
movie yet yeah no i haven't when you see
the movie it
all makes sense thank you yeah so i'm in
the zone
and there was this magical moment of
that day
and you as an artist will identify with
this
the whole time he's in this scene and
his father's not there
dom toretto is there but his dad isn't
coaching him
because i'm so in the pocket i'm so in
the moment
and there was a moment when we got home
and i saw that he saw that dom was no
longer there and that his father was
there and i saw a little smile on his
face
he's like hello just yeah it was a
special moment but that's a cool thing
to share though with your son that's a
really amazing moment it is because i i
didn't have to crutch him
first of all justin was going to cover
him entirely
justin lin the director but he also saw
how much how sacred
the process has to be to create to
elevate a movie
you know to create a movie of that
magnitude characters that
the world is so familiar with yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help